[ __ ] Uighur just released a video where
he says that conservatives start to talk
about lynching black people again now in
order to make his point I mean the guy
has dislocated his shoulder with the
reaching he had to do hey guys this is a
story that actually two stories that
came out almost a week ago but it's so
shocking and and I hate that it's become
normalized so that we don't even cover
it that much so I'm trying to fix that
but he did a town hall recently where it
played so it was over a week ago and
it's so shocking I had to rush to do a
cell phone but it you know this is for
the quick way that we're not civil one
caller said and you could hear it if you
were in the Town Hall as he played it
hey Al Green we've got an impeachment
for you it's gonna be yours it's
actually going to give you a short trial
before we hang your [ __ ] ass so that
is what one caller sent to Al Green
here's another caller he said well know
will Lynch all you [ __ ] [ __ ] will
you'll be hanging from a tree yeah
that's bad of course okay it's not good
that someone said that but these are
calls to a congressman by the way who
had that happened over a week ago so
he's like there are plenty more examples
right no there probably aren't because
you're pulling us from a week ago the
next call was probably a prank call play
misty for me okay so he's clearly
Republicans conservatives are calling
for the lynches of blacks one
congressman received two phone calls
those phone calls probably came in he
was waiting for a week for more didn't
get them and decided that this was what
he was going to run with let's condemn
it that's bad
anyone who made those phone calls is
probably a horrible person but that
doesn't mean that conservatives are
calling for the lynching of people now
in shanks defense he does name one local
representative in Mississippi so let's
show that so that we're not being
misleading because this is the strongest
case he makes politicians so there's a
Republican member of the Mississippi
House of Representatives his name is
Carl Oliver so here's what he wrote
in a recent Facebook post I don't know
open again this is stuff is brazen he
said the destruction of these monuments
erected in the land should tell you
something
fam races we're always racist is heinous
and [ __ ] rific if if the and I use the
term extremely loosely quote leadership
of Louis Louisiana wishes to in the and
not seus fashion ironic burn books are
destroying historical monuments of art
our history they should be and this is
capitalized lynched I want to be really
clear here but go watch the entire video
I encourage you to watch it for context
he does nothing but talk about extreme
examples of people who we openly condemn
on a regular basis that Mississippi
Representative uh seems like a horrible
person I don't know they were calling
for the literal lynching of black people
it seems like they were upset about the
the Confederate Monument but let's just
a either way horrible choice of words
not someone that I would vote for okay
here's the thing you had to reach so far
over to some phone calls to a
congressman and one local Republican
representative to then paint an entire
group of people again the conservative
group of people the video as
conservatives starting to call for the
lynching of black people so it is a
trend worth noting doesn't mean that
every Republican Billy transoid doesn't
mean every Republican politician
believes it but there are some
conservatives out there now openly
talking about lynching black people and
so we should not normalize that we
should not accept it we should call it
out for what it is by the way I'm going
to present to you exhibit C look how bad
it's gotten
hey the youtube comment section as you
ever see the definition of trend yeah of
trip he says to this is a noticeable
trend okay for it to be a noticeable
trend again let's go back to there needs
to be a graph and x-axis a y-axis there
needs to be some kind of causation for
this correlation is there an increased
number of racially based hate crimes
being committed he'll say yes but that's
actually not true
is there an increased number of
congressmen getting phone calls or
people are calling for the lynching and
black lynching of black people in are
they on the record as Republican voters
two dots barely makes a line he brings
up two phone calls and one local
representative super-super fringe
far-right
guy who will never be supported by
Republicans just like David Duke wasn't
actively supported by a majority of
Republicans once it came out that he was
who he was okay there's no way that that
can occur so he pulls out these fringe
people the only ones he could find and
he was scraping the bottom of the barrel
to the plumber he only found two and
says look conservatives want to lynch a
black people whereas when it comes to
the extreme policies at the left and
I've been talking about this I don't
need to reach far I just need to pull
out your stars the stars of the DNC
platform the national stars I just need
to pull out the biggest liberal sites
that could possibly exist and their
front featured articles that's what I
pull out I don't need to go and say hey
gabrielle giffords g of some kind of
phone call there from someone who's
really incredibly violent threatening to
blow up a plan to parent abortion clinic
do you have do you have anyone no I
don't mean to do that I just go to their
single top traffic to websites and most
visible platform stars let's go right
away to mainstream the mayor of Portland
just said that the First Amendment
doesn't protect hate speech at the first
minute is not absolute
Bernie Sanders you know Bernie's if the
young turks want him to run at the ripe
old age of 95 for president he said that
a 90 percent tax rate isn't too much he
also said that bread lines aren't
necessarily a bad thing we're going to
play a game here when we put Bernie
Sanders quotes or Stalin's quotes and
you can't tell the difference it's a fun
game but Tom Perez we talked about this
last week Tom Perez representative what
an answer is freedom of speech absolute
will you defend freedom of speech he
couldn't he wouldn't answer just like
you have other people a national
platform for the DNC who will not answer
that the first one is absolutely let's
go back to the the BuzzFeed abortion
video you have Elizabeth Warren and the
mainstream platform of today's DNC is
abortion on demand taxpayer-funded
period they are fighting for legislation
to allow abortions terminations of lives
to occur after 20 weeks which according
to their own presentations as you just
saw from BuzzFeed is at a point where
the baby has a beating heart and the
ability to feel pain this is Elizabeth
Warren it's Bernie Sanders it's you're
Hillary Clinton's it's your Young Turks
it's your huffington post's the people
who we target and rebut on a regular
basis are you're a
they are your all-stars so stop trying
to build up straw man by finding some
local radio disc jockeys phone list and
finding something that could be
construed as offensive start bringing
out some real arguments that you want to
rebut and then we can have a
conversation and you can find us and
come on this show but of course we know
that would be inconvenient kind of like
a pregnancy that occurs when you don't
want it to like this video subscribe by
clicking the button it's a circular
button now that says subscribe if not
head on over the Young Turks that's
probably more your speed although
they're coming over here [ __ ] we know
you're here watching I can smell you
from here there's also recommended video
box playing right up there you can join
the hmong club a lot of with credit.com
slash mug club for daily content so
we're not dependent here on youtube
shank go/no-go you don't need to stay
here this isn't good for it's bad for
your soul